how how do you find all of these weird
places that you pick sometimes I don't
know even I don't know how far like your
contacts go I try to have to go whaty f
Japan kind of content and you know like
he's waiting the Conor is still waiting
to try anything the first of try with
like a cute why don't we to make cute 3D
L art and from there I was like oh how
about this and how about that and of
course I always like asking beforehand
of course we always feel like it's a
surprise and I kind of try to like
torture you but I always just Gasper I
me he is like a human like experiment
like he's like a hamster he's just down
for anything I think the people do these
weird things they got to have a reason
why they like doing it maybe if I do it
I can kind of find a little bit of the
reason why they like doing some of these
strange things and have you found that
reason or well listen if for the pole
dancing video If I had a body like SEMA
I'm sure I would be pul danc for sure
yeah that man was like like a Greek god
pH and then he would just hold his
entire body weight up with one hand yeah
and then he's just dancing with like
really like Attractive people
and I'm sure it just
seems and then in the dancing place we
go there and all these women and men are
just freaking out watching him and I'm
like yeah I think I get it like I get
this like I think I get it for him but
for me it is but he was so fun Sima was
so fun and eventually you're okay to do
that on the strip dancing that is my far
the most awkward thing I think I've ever
done in my life oh wow he's okay with
that yeah I CU I remember that that
video so the premise was that SEMA was
doing a show is a PO dancing guy think
he's also like he came like third in the
pole dancing World Championship or
something he's like one of the best po
dancers in the world um but just
casually does these kind of like yeah he
Embraces his sexuality and he puts
together these like very interesting
shows that are kind of like I I guess he
just rents out a nightclub M and then
just kind of tells people he's doing a
show and then people just turn up it's
it's very odd
it's like he doesn't waito is
coming like very like kind of I don't
know how to like not scuff but it's like
it's kind of very like hey we're just
putting this thing together come on show
up yeah and I go to it and uh it was
just yeah he was very magic Mikey it was
yeah I felt like I was in like budet
Japanese magic par and he triying to
teach me the stce and I remember he was
teaching me this dance in like in like a
manga Cafe he's in this manga Cafe room
oh yeah internet cafe he tiny room and
he's trying to do the dense moves but
the walls are too small I thinking like
godamn but sea was very funny so I I was
like yeah it would be fun and then uh he
was the single moment where I felt like
oh my God this is like at my limit of
cringe I can take said he we we start
dancing and then he's like okay just run
up to someone and start grinding on them
and I was like
dude and I remember I had to I had to do
it I felt so bad for you coo cuz I I had
to like awkwardly grind
and I was the whole time I was grinding
on you I was like I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm so sorry you were like it's okay
it's okay so that is the behind the
scenes of awkward ha yeah for sure so
many awkward so many awkward moments in
so many videos though that's how it goes
when you do these awkward stuff though
yeah but because is a stripping like
magic mic thing I was like that's why I
kind of I was like G to shoot that uh
you know you you talk about that on
trust I know that I said oh it's a term
Jose Y in Japanese but face for women to
um you know get the sexual crime ax like
happy
ending I thought it it's like a very
interesting then I I check on the
internet like there was no single
article in English about that so I like
oh wait like this should be featured
this should talk about so I was like
kind of coordinating uh for an article
and I was coordinating with like a
smaller YouTuber I was like um he might
be okay because I didn't want to hide
any content from you so I was like how
about this but he you thought about it I
I knew like it was too Ry for big
YouTubers I spent 24 hours finger
blasting
women I saw the video that you ended up
doing there uh and man it there was just
this one funny shot where I guess you
and uh Tristan are both just in the
corner watching this woman being just
watching and we're just commentating
like we're trying to be quiet at the
same time like know we can just watch
and we have stuck it's it's YouTube it's
like it's like silently sitting with
your best friend on a couch watching
porn together but like nothing is
happening you just watching imagine it
would be a very funny video but I also
would feel so bad if it I came out kind
of making fun of someone who's just like
yeah I'll let you film me
getting kind of a moment where you'd
expect to be your most like intimate and
private
moment what did the woman like was she
okay with it like yeah she was totally
fine I think if she watch he watched
more than what we saw on the JB video
yeah yeah yeah totally yeah like way
more I just yeah it's it's I I don't
know I can't imagine cuz like yeah as
you were saying like it's like you know
in a private room right so you'd think
it's like you know I really want to get
intimate with this guy and I want to
feel good by the way don't mind the two
guys in the corner just like staring at
me just pretend they not there it's fine
it's so posc exactly just pretend
they're not there it's fine and she was
coming I I forgot that like I don't know
if I watched the entire video but there
are so many risky content yeah I think
she got tied up like I think it was
shown in the video like with like a red
rope and yeah because you'd pitch the FL
placees me you like Conor this's is a
place where you can get a massage but
they'll also help the woman climax which
is super
[Applause]
vague but I mean as I I wanted to make a
video but I was like man I just don't
think I can think of anywh I could show
anything yeah and know monetization yeah
yeah I think it'd be a very funny 30-
second shot in a video about something
else we're like and we did this and then
you're just like it's me in the corner
going oh God I mean it's bang of patreon
content imagine one person actually
coming in for a massage though and
you're like
wait where's the
climaxing I even like ask about legality
and yes if as long as they don't
penetrate it's fine like it's still
that's crazy I didn't know that in [__]
you can do everything but penetrate and
be you can pay for that yes like you can
actually have a business if you need a
permission for that but I mean I feel
like J Japan it's so wellknown and so
accessible I just
wonder why the hell haven't they just
try to make some form of it legal and
make it more safe yeah it's it's well
it's another loophole in a loophole
right gambling too yeah like gambling
you Japanese businesses are very good at
finding the loopholes that you can get
away with legally I just I just like to
imagine there just a bunch of Japanese
lawmakers who are just not honest with
themselves you know they're just like Oh
No gambling is bad prostitution is bad
meanwhile in secretly behind the corner
they're like [__] how do we make this
legal without making us look weird you
know see it's it's it's one of two
options either they like they genuinely
just don't know about it and it's just
like a lot of it's just like a lot of
old people that are just like out of
touch with what's really going on or
they know about it and they might get
some percentage you know yeah yeah yeah
right but yeah reminds me cuz like sydne
was telling me about this place called
it was like called like a pink theater
or something like that have you heard
about this yes pink Cinema guess pink
Cinema yes I me do you want do you want
to explain what it
is still like R like a doubt film but
it's not
AV right right see I I I I was under the
impression that it was a place where you
could watch r18 films and people can go
to these
Cinemas uh
and uh you know do the business they
need to do while the fil is being played
acted out out there's still a few of
them around I think that yeah likeo
or I know has them I've heard about this
there just cinas where you just go to
jack off yeah and like in back in those
days I was asked to St in those films
too of course the payment is just way
less and it's like a way lower budget
but still yeah how you been doing by the
way it's been so many years since we uh
we were able to catch up you've been
doing a lot yeah you guys not too look
at oh the March like go you guys love
that at time your right yes this my new
Wu cup yeah actually drawn by Gansu
mangaka hya oku oh yeah is so good yeah
I made like a proposal like I even like
I made a PDF and kind PowerPoint for
this because whenever I pitch to
Japanese artists they don't know about
Wu cups ORS so I make slides and yeah
commiss artist yeah it's cool right it's
supposed to be
that's that's so cool that
he how you get in contact with him in
the first place I knew him before he
interviewed me once for his new work
well it finished but it's called Uh Gant
yes ganto he interviewed you for it yeah
like he needed to get some inside of the
actresses of that field yeah oh wow and
I did interview him for crol inter know
here oh okay okay yeah you I'm always
surprised that with the
that you've made doing various different
interesting um and always endlessly
fascinating thank you I've noticed
you're going to a lot more conventions
in the US now as well how's that going
yeah it's been great and I actually
brought gamer to Convention too because
I thought they would sell well they
should have a boost and they have been
successful we went to all Theon together
this summer and they said the sales they
I think they got the highest sales AFF
for a con on one day
was not even
Saturday thank you do do you get
recognized over in America quite a lot
now yeah definitely and actually I got
like a younger and more like a female F
coming to my booth I guess to yeah
thanks to you guys thanks to I think
it's more so thanks to you just making
like good content you know but I'm not
sure what the percentage of female
audience is for trash taste but I don't
think it's rise off female audience let
yourself be known in the comments
majority it's pretty low yeah well it's
mostly guys watch right now I'm I'm Vibe
checking based on the ratios of like
most of our live shows which I think is
a good indicator a good mix actually
yeah sure but yeah I guess online set is
a bit more skewed yeah and uh you also
released your book as well English and
Japanese right the Japanese one came out
quite a while back right Japanese how
how did the English uh release go oh
yeah I think it's been read a lot and
now that I can say like whenever people
want to ask me about industry questions
like oh you can just buy my book
and stop asking me questions I'm byy the
book it's so good I love the difference
between the Japanese cover and the
English cover it's very funny how the
Japanese one is just you looking very
like polite with text boom boom boom and
English then the English one is more
like a little Saucy it's just I guess
it's the difference between the two
cultures man you got to know how to pull
the audience right yeah all right I got
I got the male to female ratio uh past
365 days what do you think take a guess
I think 90% dudes 90% dudes say 80% 80%
what do you think 75 84% male oh oh
that's not B 84% which I is probably
what I was thinking to be honest makes
sense how the age 20 years five actually
five most of them are 5ye olds
kid 46% 18 to 24 38% 25 to 34 wow we
have more we have more people between
the age of 45 and 54 who listen to us
than 13 to 17 good keep it that way yeah
let's keep it that way guys